ferals have been a Hollywood Trope since
the days of silent films but the
stereotype takes an exploitative turn
when the dangerous woman in question is
a teenager the 1992 movie poison ivy
aimed for a cross between film Noir and
Fatal Attraction in its story of a
sexually free but homicidally inclin the
casting of Drew Barrymore then in a
career rebound after struggles with drug
addiction and named players like Sarah
Gilbert and Tom scarrett attempted to
lend respectability to the sleazy ra
Barry Moore than 17 isn't particularly
convincing at depicting ivy a deranged
teen so taken with Gilbert's normal life
that she's willing to seduce her father
and kill her mother the character is
aware of her desirability but unable to
use it for anything except base interest
Barry Moore gam handles the story's most
prant aspects which include making out
with the 17-year-old Gilbert and
60-year-old scarrett and pushing Cheryl
lad off a balcony